j'ai fait vingt ans de prison je viens
d'en sortir au mac j'ai un fusil avec
moi je te préviens s'il entre dans cette
maison je vais m'en servir
gbagbo
[Musique]
votre libération modifient-elles votre
injonction d'éloignement oui ou non non
je cherche cathy
c'est ma petite ça
je les ai élevés c'est pas pour rien
boxeur vous a pas répondu vous êtes une
tueuse de flics en permanence oui
comment ta aux ir qui me dire comment
s'assurer sa défense elle a passé des
années en prison et l'a tué un policier
de sang froid elle a été traumatisée
aujourd'hui elle va bien qui aurait
intérêt à perturber cet équilibre
laissez la vivre sa vie votre vie à bout
elle commence ici maintenant je baisse
pas les bras pas pour cris
le monde et pas comme vous l'imaginiez
est ce que vous avez appris en tôle est
sans doute ce qui finira par vous y
ramener quand john vous à vue il a vu
une femme qui méritait une deuxième
chance mais c'est parce que je vois vous
avez laissé passer votre chance c'est
terminé
il n'y a pas de différence entre les
gens d'ici et les taulards
vous avez envie d'être pareil que
c'est en prison pendant huit mois
je suis désolé
c'est à faire ça
toi tu vas rester ici tu vas manger tout
ce camion
importe ce qui va se passer
je t'aimerai toute ma vie
[Musique]